Monday night ven Higgins will choose
between Lauren B and Jojo
we know he winds up engaged I love two
women but now I'm happily in love with
one and that's gonna stay that way for
the rest of my life so who does he
choose I got the bachelor family to
weigh in who would you like to see him
give that ring to in the end
me and a lot of the other girls in the
house kind of start the Tiffany and
Lauren B from leg d1 so I'd be pretty
surprised if she didn't get the final
rose I see a little more of a connection
with Lauren B's but you know you never
know I'm rooting for Lauren B Lauren B
Jojo I am team Jojo she is a great
person
I'm team Jojo all the way Lauren B I
just think no it's like the chemistry
that they have like I don't think you
can fake that you just watch the way
that they look at each other they touch
each other kiss each other seems pretty
natural
lots of Lauren B fans back in January
Tanner from Kaitlyn Bristowe season even
predicted the outcome for his pal Ben
there's a few girls that I I think would
be a good match for him Oh give me two
names two names I had to pick I would
say Jojo and boy he seems to like that
Lauren B two out they seemed the most
normal so who do you guys think Ben will
pick Monday night let me know on twitter
i'm at lauren zima